[Music]
you share that part of yourself with
somebody there's no going back
gotta ask you about the empty ring box
why is the ring box empty Colton what
does it mean where is the ring
rings are meant to be on fingers not in
boxes so who is the ring on someone's
finger I don't I don't know what you're
talking about
was there ever a ring in the box
yes sir within that box there's there's
been a ringing her that did you or Neil
Lane or someone put it in the box
uh yeah Neil Lane put it in that box
that was near lanes box so yes did you
meet me Oh Lane during filming I have
met Neil Lane yes during filming yep
during filming so you looked at some
ring well how do you feel about how
things ended things haven't ended yet
how do you feel about how filming ended
and where things were at at that point
um emotional I mean I'm in this
emotional sort of Time Warp right now so
I'm reliving it with everybody and it's
been a challenge it hasn't always been
easy filming wasn't the easiest reliving
it and watching it back wasn't the
easiest either
[Music]